Hello
Freak bitches.
I can,
my mom was cleaning houses.
It would make it $6 an hour.
My Dad,
teamster warehouse foreman and uh,
they,
we get a watch poor growing up,
lower middle class and
then went to the school.
You sent me to school in San
Francisco with all these rich kids.
So I was doing all these rich houses
and houses in, uh, if people don't know,
San Francisco at Pacific Heights
is really nice and it's old now.
It's like fucking $12 million houses
and that's where we were hanging out.
Parents would have abandoned them on
the weekends and we'd have run of these
fucking houses.
Just crazy.
Like my buddy broke a $25,000
vase and then we're like,
let's get the fuck out of here. We'll
pay for it. And we were in all these,
I was like smoking some guys
Cubans on sitting in his chair.
I'm a kid from the inner sunset district
who shouldn't be all of these places,
but I think that's what lit a fire under
my ass because I'm working for the,
my mom eventually has just great rags
to riches story where she was working at
this company and then she became an
account rep and then she became the head
account Rep.
Then she began to vice president.
Then she bought the company and
quadrupled the company in size. Wow.
And that's where I went to work for her.
Even though I wanted to be a
standup comic, I go to work for her.
I am firing people for living,
which is a whole nother fucking thing.
And just say I really was
forced into this. Very tough.
My Dad and my mom were very
fucking brutal. Half Mexican,
half Sicilian. I could have, again,
I could have been up there and
miserable fucking with, you know,
firing people nonstop.
And it's like taking on other people's
problems because that's what I did is
like if you have a business
or you work somewhere,
we'd employ everybody working there.
So you didn't have to deal
with any of the headaches.
But then I got all the headaches,
so I've been chased like a,
I had a guide who was a Taiwan knees,
like you sick this banner.
He was working in a doctor's office,
but on the weekends we found out
he was pretending he was the doctor
who's seeing patients, his own patients.
But he's a physical therapist and uh,
um,
orthopedists office.
So I go in there and I've been
doing this awhile and again,
I've been in so many awkward situations
now I'm doing stand up and I'm even more
awkward situations and I just
go up and I go, hey Twon,
you know, Jig is up. I go, today's your
last day. We find out what you're doing.
He grabs me,
puts me up against the wall,
he gets one of those physical
therapy sticks, you know the big,
like the pole that you stretch
with behind your back and stuff.
And he has one of those cut in half
and he sticks it right up to my throat.
And now I'm cool. And
so I go, Twan, I got,
you got two choices here.
You're going to hit me with that stick
and I'm going to call the cops and I'm
going to press, you're going
to go to jail. Somebody piss.
He hit me with that fucking stick.
Or you can take the final check that's
in my breast pocket right here and walk
away.
What's it going to be?
And I'm held up against the wall by
my throat with the fucking stick,
our face and so had some crazy situation.
So I'm, what did you say to him?
You said the Jig is up. I know you're
not a real doctor. Yeah. I go, hey,
how you doing? You shouldn't be here right
now. We know you're seeing response. No,
this is not true. You know like in Chula,
like you going to go, he spoke English.
Yeah. She's a physical therapist. You
banging chicks too? I have no idea.
I would liked it to be that way.
Yeah. That's a better story.
If there's a way to heal you.
I lost my car.
So I had Russian nurses running from
me and just crazy stories like why were
they trying to do too? Yeah. Uh,
well this Russian nurse was
in an allergist's office
and she was giving wrong
doses to the kids and stuff of shots.
So I had all my documentation,
like these yellow pads that goes, there's,
um, we, you see, right. I'm 22 years old.
You can see right here, Dan,
she tries to grab it now.
It's a tug of war across a desk and I
don't know what the fuck is going on.
And um,
she takes off and runs down a
hallway and I'm 22 and I go, shit,
I fucking run down the hallway afterwards
and she goes into a patient room and
10,
she locks the door and then I get the
door open and she told somebody to unlock
it and she's in there and she's talking
to her husband on the phone. She goes,
I'm through, there was a mum here who's
telling me lies. He's telling me lies.
I didn't want to tell you this.
I am pregnant and I'm going to
lose the baby because of his mom.
Oh my God.
Totally freaking out.
So I had a tea to teach.
A bunch of Vietnamese people had a shit
and it was one day I got a call. Wait,
I got a call from the sky issue.
Well they were her mungs. Okay.
You know what Hmong is like
if you saw a grand Torino,
that movie with Clint Eastwood,
I think the H is silent.
I think the h m o u n g is and yeah.
And then there are people without a land.
Yeah.
And then they call came to San Jose,
California to work in assembly plants.
So they're in this cable assembly pant.
A plant called Cable Co.
That was a big client of ours. And I
got a call from this really cool guy.
His name is chip chip bronc. And he
goes, Al, you got to get down here.
You're not going to fucking believe it.
And I got a situation and I go,
what is it? And it goes better. You see
when to go into the bathroom,
Shit. Everywhere. What?
Cause they had never been used to toilets.
So they were standing on the toilet seats.
I found out that's what was going on.
They all had fake names
like the names Food Kelly.
But you can call me Keith
like, Hey Keith, fluke,
Lee, can you come here for a
second? Can I tell you about this?
The shit everywhere. Like on the
ground. Yeah, there were missing
a toilet seat is not fucking hold you up.
So they're waddling up there standing
on the standing on the toilets.
So they were just used to like shitting
and shitting in holes. Oh my God.
If they're lucky, you know, in the
woods or whatever. Jesus Christ.
So have you been lucky? Not
Lucky where they hold it
forever. Yeah, just backed up.
It's becomes a brick.
Yeah. So, um, anyway,
I gathered everybody around.
I just appointed a bathroom
monitor and oh my God,
a bathroom monitor. So I had one
on the guys who was a supervisor.
I had a clipboard. I put a lock
on the map room door. And then,
so you become this corporate fixer.
That's what I was doing.
And I always wanted to do standup comedy.
I love standup comedy.
I grew up in the city, which is
listening to comedians on the radio.
And all the great comments was
two comics who lived on my block.
And so I love lived on your block,
Mike Pritchard and Michael Meehan,
two great comics. Mike Pritchard, one the
first San Francisco comedy competition.
And Ron Williams looked up to him and he
was like, [inaudible]. That was his idol.
And he was on my block. And you don't
money Hoffman. Yeah, money Hoffman.
I would be eight years old on my
bike and I'd ride down the block.
And Mani Hoffman and Mike Pritchard
used to put their tee shirts over their
heads. You know how you can do like
just the face pops out of the hole.
And they used to pretend they
were the California raisin guys.
You guys are hilarious.
This is amazing.
Yeah.